ما هي احتمالات أن يخدع فلاديمير بوتين
، فهناك دائمًا
فرصة ولكن كل مؤشر على
أننا رأينا كل خطوة قام
بها والتي
اتبعت أه المسرحية التي وضعناها
ليراها العالم أمام
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة هو
يتابع النص تقريبًا إلى الرسالة لذا
أه
أعتقد أه بينما هناك دائمًا فرصة ،
كل ما نراه أه يوحي
بأن هذا أمر خطير للغاية أننا
على شفا غزو وسنفعل
كل ما نفعله  يمكن أن نحاول منعه
قبل حدوثه ولكن بنفس القدر
نحن مستعدون إذا أه إذا
اتبع أه لفرض
عواقب وخيمة للدفاع عن أه لتوفير
دفاع أوكرانيا أه المستمر
وإه لدعم الناتو وهنا مرة أخرى ما هو
اللافت في هذا  هل
سيكون الرئيس بوتين قد عجل بكل ما
سعى إلى منعه لأن كل هذا
قد عزز فقط حلف شمال الأطلسي وعزز
تضامنه والتزامه أه
وعزز بالفعل الناتو أه في مهمته  الجناح الخلفي ،
كنت في ميونيخ مع كل
قادة شركائنا
الأوروبيين وأعتقد أننا جميعًا ، نحن
الذين كنا نفعل هذا منذ سنوات عديدة
، لم نشهد أبدًا وقتًا كان فيه
الناتو أكثر
توحيدًا وأعتقد أنه سيذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك  أظهر
أنه إذا أه إذا تابع بوتين
الغزو